- So you have thoughts
on Valentine's Day here.
- Well, yes, Valentine's
Day is coming up very soon
and I feel like every
year guys screw it up.
(laughter and applause)
- Lookin' at you.
- Not the park guy, not the park guy.
So I have some ideas for guys
that are watching the show
that want some advice, so I'm
gonna, where am I lookin'?
Oh, I'm gonna look into
here, the guy up there,
I'm looking at you, sir.
If you're buying--
(drum loudly beats)
(gentle band music)
(laughter)
- No one warned you, no one warned you.
All of the sudden my band, they
just really wanna be a part,
you know, so they just start playing.
- Oh, my God!
Oh, God, okay!
- We were playing music under your PSA.
- Oh, geez, okay, all right.
Whew, I'm sweating!
Look, I'm sweating now, look!
(laughter and applause)
- You are!
You can't see on black, it's black.
- Okay, advice for the guys,
you ready goatee in the back?
- [Kelly] (laughs) Goatee.
- All right, if you're
buying ladies a gift
for Valentines Day, get a gift card.
I know, it's impersonal.
Get a gift card, I promise you,
I promise you, I promise you
(audience applause and cheers)
it will be less of a fight
then buying something
in the wrong size.
(laughter)
Also, if you are buying
something for your girlfriend
of two or more years and
decide to buy her jewelry
that's not an engagement ring,
I suggest you give her that
jewelry box wearing a helmet.
(laughter and applause)
'Cause you're about
to get concussed, sir.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- Godspeed.
- See?
Thank you.
- Godspeed.